Bán trường OSA vừa công buồn để xuất ám dụng các biển pháp thương mại và chính trị, nhằm đắt trả chính dịch quân sự của Israel tại giả các giá.
Theo đỏ Rú Sen, một tăng thời với hàng yếu khẩu từ Israel, chủ yếu lên năm sản.
Đúng thái này có thể làm chỉ phí sất khẩu của Israel tăng hơn 2.0.
Bên cảnh đỏ OSA cũng đề nghĩ đóng bán tại sản và tấm tị thật với 2 bụ trường cực hiểu trong sinh phủ của tụi đường bán cho mình nên tà cho hút.
Là ông I Tamarbén Divier và Bên Zaléu Smotrick, Hà Vy này, tường xuyên của những phát nôn mai palestín và theo gọi sắp nơi phỏng toàn dạ gà dạ.
Phó trước từ gửi bán cho OSA, phủ trách đường ngoại và gà hà cá lắt nhìn mạnh, một theo chính của các lệnh Trung phát là cảnh thiện tình hành hành hành hành hành hành hành đạo ở dạ gà dạ.
Không phải tạo một con hệ càng tháng với Israel.
Tuy nhiên các bạn phát này có thông qua, gió ủ vận chiều ZEV chính xe trung đông khi lệnh Trung phát cần sự nhất chỉ của tòn bộ 2 mấy nước thành viên,
còn bình phát thông ma chỉ đoài hỏi đa số đủ đu ciet, sau vẫn bị đen giá khó đát đường thần.
Chong dịt biến lưng quan tẩy giải gà dạ.
Cô đo Israel thông báo sẽ mở hành lát xưa tán tạm thời, qua phủ sẽ là Adi hoạt động khoảng 4.000 tạm dơ từ ngày mấy bạn tháng chính.
Nằm đường người dân thành phố gà dạ về phía năm.
Tình đến nay khoảng 186.000 người dân đã dời khỏi thành phố lưới nước giải gà dạ.
Như tình trạng ác tắc nghiêm trọng vẫn xe dạ trên các đường xe tán.